um hi everyone
um it is such a delight to be here I
think a lot about augmented
documentation and helping people read
complex information and Stanford is just
a really fun pilgrimage in that regard
um this is the one of the places where
Don knuth worked and developed Tech the
program that we use to create our
research papers there's also a number of
really exciting projects around creating
interactive textbooks and interactive
reading materials for children that I
think are also really inspiring for the
type of work that I take on too so it's
just really exciting to be here at this
environment sharing this set of work in
this place where a lot of really cool
historical work has taken place on this
topic so the focus of today's talk is
designing the interactive paper
and I think a lot about building
interactive information interfaces that
help people interact with and understand
complex information and I think one of
the environments in which we interact
with complex information that I think is
often hiding in plain sight is our PDF
reader for scientific papers
and I think if you're looking for a
complex information presentation you
really can't get much more complex than
the scientific paper and one of the
reasons that there's many reasons for
this um to name just one of the reasons
for this it's the vocabulary within
scientific papers so for instance within
a very within an individual paper you're
going to perhaps encounter many
different acronyms
perhaps symbols and other types of
formalisms that people use to encode
certain types of ideas you'll also see a
lot of invented terms so we researchers
like to assign new shiny names to the
things that we do and explore new
Concepts so inevitably you're going to
have some of this invention of new terms
that haven't been seen in other
documents before and one of the
challenges with reading papers is that
simply there's this over abundance of
these of these instances of vocabulary
and then when you consider understanding
in all of these different levels when it
comes to understanding an individual
term to understanding a sentence and the
propositions that it entails and so
understanding the larger Concepts that
come apart from a paper as a whole this
ultimately results in a large amount of
extraneous load as someone is trying to
piece together the ideas within that
paper
and as someone who myself thinks a lot
about interaction design well it's
natural for me to ask this question of
how could interaction help us read
papers like this one
and there's a lot of history a lot of
historical work that's been done in
building uh Advanced reading interfaces
that can provide us some inspiration
that suggests that we can actually
provide interactions that help people
with reading so let me share a few of my
favorite example projects
um up on the screen here you can see a
tablet app that's called inquire biology
and this is an interactive biology
textbook for the tablet that was meant
for for school level biology instruction
and some of the features within this
tool was essentially they would
automatically process the entire biology
text extract out a bunch of entities and
relationships and then they could make
definitions of individual terms
available on click such as for
concentration gradient that you can see
there
they also supported
um Institute question and answering so
they would from these lists of entities
and relationships that would populate
these lists of questions that people
could ask and then in the margins of the
text you can write these questions and
see the answers right there
another version that I think most of us
have encountered in one form or another
is Wikipedia page previews so um one of
the issues with Wikipedia with having
all of this interlinked information is
that
um in order to truly understand a
subject oftentimes you need to click
through multiple different links and one
way that Wikipedia has sought to try to
facilitate kind of this multi-document
reading a little bit better is um a
while ago they introduced these page
previews where you can highlight where
you can hover over a link and we'll show
you a little blurb from the page that's
linked to including a brief text
description and perhaps an image and
this might be just enough for someone to
understand enough so they can continue
reading without having to delve into
that page
one of my favorite examples comes from
source code reading so one of the lines
of research that we're doing in in my
group relates to a source code
comprehension and understanding some of
the most complex programs and um there
have been years and years of work that
have gone into helping people understand
complex programs and so if you take
something like the vs code Source editor
um some of the features that you might
see is for instance the ability to hover
over individual functions or variables
and you can see any documentation that's
associated with that variable or
function there's also some of these cool
features around doing some analysis of
the code to understand which parts of it
are dead or irrelevant and so what you
can see is that in this particular file
the variable is absolute Tech path and
Tech name are low lighted which means
that they're not actually used anywhere
else in the program and so this is one
way that you can help help attract
someone's attention to certain places
that are necessary and kind of directed
away from the places where it's not
here's a project called bookbuddy that's
actually from a Stanford research group
and this is meant for young children and
what it does is it embeds this
conversational agent directly within the
book reading experience and allows
interactions around for instance
um you know quizzes that can be seen
right alongside the text
um here's one more example that I
particularly love so um there's this
project called the Voyager interactive
book series back in the mid 90s and they
experimented with a lot of these
different ways of being able to bring
interactivity
um into into into the documents that we
read
um including um in this particular book
by Don Norman things that make us smart
um Don Norman himself who will come in
and uh and give his own editorializing
on some of the content uh with it within
the book so if you were to click on Don
Norman
um here's the additional explanation
that he would provide that little tiny
rectangle the clothes box
Kathy at the cursor exactly over it and
click it in order to get rid of me can
we turn up your volume hard to reach
hard to hit
I think
if I have control over this
let's try this one more time
that little tiny rectangle the closed
box
Hefty at the cursor exactly over it's a
little bit flaky but essentially what
Don Norman is doing is he's talking
about hard to read the difficulty of
understanding what that little close box
and the edge of a window is going to is
going to be able to provide the
functionality of dismissing that window
so this is one particular instantiation
of an interactive text where you provide
these uh these explanations that are
provided by real people directly within
the text I think it's a timely time I
think it's I think it's a timely
question to ask what are the different
ways in which we can abuse some of these
affordances bring some of these
affordances into scientific papers
because
um there's a large number of initiatives
to try to bring interactivity to papers
so for instance the semantic scholar
team which I work very closely with is
very interested in being able to build
out interactive papers
um to supplement their scholarly search
engine and you can also see on Portals
like E-Life lens science direct
researchgate and a number of different
services that we encounter every day
that they're experimenting with
interaction in many different ways which
ultimately raises this question of what
an interactive paper should do
and
um the the spoilers for this talk is
that I'm going to try to convince all of
you of a set of functionality that I
think interactive paper should have why
I think that that's the case and what it
would take to actually build interactive
papers that provided this functionality
and so what I would pose is that perhaps
an interactive paper should first at
least Define terms so when someone
selects a term that they don't
understand for instance the name of this
method and this table of results in this
machine learning paper it should provide
a definition of that term in context
I also think that it should help explain
notation so for instance perhaps it
should make definitions of Expressions
within mathematical formulas available
to people and perhaps at multiple levels
of resolution too where you could click
click down click to drill down into
individual sub Expressions to understand
those as well
I think an interactive paper should
enliven the static so rather than having
a derivation that appears like this one
that you can see on the left that
essentially kind of extrudes this this
formula into multiple snapshots over
time maybe instead you can convey the
same information by for instance
highlighting certain expressions of
interest and Visually showing how one of
those formulas transforms into another
through for instance use of animation
and I think an interactive paper should
also simplify the complex so given a
very complex passage like this one from
a biomedical paper perhaps it should be
possible for someone to access a
simplification of that text that will
allow them to access
um to understand the basic contents of
that text at a glance before they invest
the time of reading that whole passage
in Greater detail
so that's the basic set of affordances
that I'll be talking about today
and while talking about these I'll be
talking about how in order to arrive at
these interactions and try to develop
them in a satisfying way we both need an
understanding of readers precise
interactions with scientific articles we
also need to apply text analyzes of
various kinds to different
representations of the scientific
articles and then we usually design
powerful tightly integrated interactive
features within those articles
and the methodology that I use for for
This research is one that I think should
be very familiar to many of you which is
a technical HDI approach We Begin much
of this work with formative studies and
then we iteratively construct systems
bringing together both um you know
interactive prototyping as well as
different types of text analyzes and
ultimately evaluate these systems in
both lab and other types of settings as
well
so now that you have a sense of the
vision of this work you can consider the
rest of this talk is divided into
essentially four chapters the first
three where we talk about these three
different types of main affordances that
an interactive paper should perhaps have
and then talking about an agenda for
what it would take to really kind of
bring this interactive interactive
papers Vision to fruition
and one of the things that I'll note is
that for these first two talks I'm a
person who thinks a lot about formalisms
and notations we will spend a lot of
time talking about notation and symbols
and then that last chapter chapter um
the the chapter on simplifying the
complex will bring it back to text
comprehension more broadly
so let's talk about what it would take
to make interactive papers that could
Define terms and symbols
we can take this back to the initial uh
to the initial motivation that I shared
with you that essentially within an
individual paper if you want to
understand the contents of that paper
oftentimes you need to orient yourself
with many acronyms symbols and invented
terms that have been introduced within
that paper
and one might think that a solution to
this problem would be relatively simple
for instance couldn't you just take a
given symbol or a given term within a
paper and then you just show the the
definition of it right adjacent to that
term or simple
um we'll talk a little bit more about
what what it would actually take to to
bring this to reality something Nuance
in the design in a second
um there's reason to believe that in a
short amount of time we will have
definition detection technology that
we'll be able to find all these
definitions of terms and symbols within
papers for instance um there's a number
of different types of techniques around
the automatic definition detection that
can for instance take in a sentence like
TL is transfer learning and derive from
it both the terms that are mentioned
within this sentence as well as the
definitions that are produced and these
uh these techniques are producing better
results year by year for instance in
2021 my colleagues dang yup Kang
produced a state of the art model that
was achieving 70 F1 which is pretty good
it's starting to get into the realm of
reality still has a ways to go but again
now now that we're in 2023 as we see
more and more advances with large
language models this is bringing this
increasingly closer to reality
so assuming that we have these back ends
um then this brings us to this design
problem of let's say given a symbol like
this letter H and given a definition
like attention head and also given the
fact that it appears in this passage
that has many other instances of that
letter H and many other symbols and
terms this raises the question of how
should a reader request information
about a symbol like this I want
information about H should they be shown
and so the exercise I want to pose to
all of you is when you spend 30 seconds
thinking yourself about what it would
look like to effectively request
information for this symbol and then
what it would look like to present
information effectively to someone
following that request
so now that you've had some time to
think up your own uh your own solution
to this problem I want to talk through
some of the Nuance that you might have
noticed in trying to surface
definitional information
so a first challenge is simply that
these terms and symbols appear within
dense passages and so any information
that you surface is necessarily going to
occlude other texts with net passage
that someone might be still be
referencing in order to understand that
sentence that they're reading and so you
want to minimize that occlusion
a second challenge is that symbols terms
as well but symbols especially are often
understood in context someone's so
someone's task might not necessarily be
to understand an individual symbol but
rather to understand the larger
structures in which they appear for
instance within formulas
a third challenge is that symbols in
particular are compositional and so
um it's not necessarily enough to expose
information about high-level symbols but
you might want to allow people to drill
down to multiple different levels so um
I want to pose another question to you
which is how many symbols are in the
equation that you see on the screen
you heard a seven
is the equals a symbol
our parentheses symbol
so
so it becomes a bit ambiguous and it
also is a bit reader dependent too but
one of the things that I would wager is
that there are at least 12 symbols
within this formula where if you look at
the lowest level of this formula like if
you were to turn into a parse tree and
just look at the leaf nodes you would
have m h and J on the left hand side as
your kind of lowest level symbols that
someone might want to understand and at
the next level up you have another three
which are these kind of higher level
terms and then you might also have the
equals and like in parentheses too but I
would say that it's at least 12 and you
would want someone to be able to access
helpful information about each of these
and the fourth challenge is that symbols
often have multiple meanings too so for
instance here I pulled two examples from
one specific paper in which T was used
in three different senses here you can
see two of them in one case T is using
this Matrix transposition operator and
in another one it means the number of
token representations
and so from this you you might start to
see how simply saying throw a tool tip
at it is not necessarily kind of a
sufficient solution you need some
attention to some of this nuance
and for us we ended up distilling this
down into a set of seven requirements
around providing these position
sensitive definitions of terms and
symbols within papers and this was on
the basis of five formative studies that
we conducted including interviews
observations focus groups and so on and
so forth with different iterations of
our interactive reader at different
times
and all together we ended up bringing
all of this together and reifying it in
a tool that we called scholarify
and skullify tries to encode some of
this Nuance about how you surface some
of this definition information within an
interactive paper let me walk you
through what it would look like to
interact with a paper with scholarify
so the first feature with scholarfi is
simply supporting this multiple level
kind of drill down to access definitions
of individual symbols so if you wanted
to get to that H right by the cursor the
way that you would get to it is you
would first click on the parent symbol
and then once that went clicked you can
see that a number of sub targets become
available within that symbol which you
can then click and if you have kind of a
mega symbol that has multiple levels of
subscripts essentially what will happen
is you just you click on kind of the
grandparent element and you continually
drill down into the sub elements this
ends up supporting an efficient way of
accessing those definitions in a way
that all of those definitions are
somehow available
and then as someone clicks on their
symbols and terms what you'll see is
this compact definition tooltip which
has been designed for economy so that it
does not include the surrounding text
and it has a few of these main
components to it of course first it has
the definition that's kind of the key
component you can't leave out then it
has this hyperlink to the definition in
context because oftentimes we understand
these terms and symbols by the company
that they keep and we want to jump to
those passages to learn more about them
and then there are also these buttons
that open up lists of definitions
formulas and usages and those um those
little buttons too even provide scent
unto themselves by if they're disabled
that suggests there's only one sense of
that term or symbol if they're enabled
then you can even hover over them to get
a sense of how many terms and symbols
and it'll open up those lists in the
sidebar
and so when someone clicks on that link
to the definition in context again we're
trying to go to the work of reducing
extraneous load trying to do as much
work on the behalf of a of a reader as
possible we highlight the passage that
the definition came from that individual
sentence in blue to be able to attract
someone's attention to it right away
you you'll also see this feature of when
someone clicks on an individual formula
that they want to understand we try to
support uh bringing together multiple of
these definitions that might need to
understand it at once so someone can
click on that equation diagram and what
they'll see is the definitions for all
of the symbols at each of the different
levels of hierarchy at which they're
available and they're arrayed on the
outside of this formula using a simple
automatic label layout algorithm so that
someone can rapidly check up on the
definitions of individual symbols all
side by side
and because once again you know um the
the meaning of a turmeric symbol can
often be determined based on the company
that it keeps someone might be
interested in seeing all of these usages
in context really quickly and so we
introduced this feature that we call
declutter which means that when someone
clicks on a term like this DNM that you
can see right here what happens is that
all passages that contain it are
automatically highlighted all of the
remaining ones are low lighted and
Visually de-emphasized what this allows
someone to do is to once again find out
all of the information in context within
the paper for this term by simply just
scrolling through the paper and looking
at those emphasized passages
so altogether those interactions the
main philosophy behind all of them is
trying to consolidate this explanatory
information about the terms and symbols
while also trying to reduce occlusion
in order to get a sense of how an
interaction like this could support the
reading experience we conducted Indian
lab usability study we had 27
researchers come and and we had them
undertake both time tasks as well as
unstructured ones in the time tasks we
asked them questions that required an
understanding of the terms and symbols
and in the open-ended task we asked them
to read the paper for 20 minutes of
unstructured reading time using the
features however they chose
what we ended up seeing is that for the
for the timed tasks when participants
were asked to answer questions that
required an understanding of the terms
and symbols they were capable of doing
so in significantly less time and they
also viewed Less in the paper and
traversed significantly less of the
paper and at the same time they also
reported significantly higher ease and
confidence in doing so the type of
effect that you would hope for if you're
trying to reduce extraneous load is
people are trying to answer some of
these fine understand these fine-grained
aspects of the text
and then when we observe people using uh
using these features we started to see a
couple of Trends so out of the features
that we produced the definition tool
tips and the equation diagrams were seen
as kind of the Home Run knock it out of
the park essentially all participants
said that they would use them often or
always if they were present and I
believe almost all if not all
participants used them during the
unstructured reading task the declutter
feature was also used and seen as useful
but to a lesser extent the definition
tooltips and equation diagrams were
really kind of those main features
we also started to see some of these
emergent behaviors that we would expect
to arise in more naturalistic reading
settings when someone has some of these
kind of primitive tools at their
disposal so um some of my own favorites
were one participant who is using these
tool tips not just to throw themselves
in on the meaning of a term to begin
with but to check their understandings
kind of administer a self-mini quiz
right in the middle of reading another
example was a was a was a reader who who
read a technical section by jumping from
one equation to to the other and just
looking at the equation diagrams and
skipping the interleaving texts and
these are essentially kind of resembling
to what we think are a bunch of things
that people would try to do to scaffold
their reading in different ways once
these Primitives became available
now this was our first project in the
augmented reading space but at the same
time it was enough for us I was
collaborating with the semantic scholar
team they make a they make a a free
online literature search engine
um and we were all excited Enough by
these results um that they started on
this product product initiative called
the semantic reader to try to bring some
of this interactive reading to the
semantic Scholars site these days it has
some features around helping people
understand citations and they're also
experimenting with more and more if you
follow its Twitter feeds you can be part
of some of the pilot studies for some of
those tools
um so all that to say um this was
something that that ended up leading to
some of these longer longer initiatives
that you'll continue to see some of the
work that is Arisen out of
now um the research effort around around
this work is not just to understand kind
of the top half of this slide that you
can see here around what the user
interfaces should look like around
interactive papers but to also
understand some of the Nuance around the
things that we might have overlooked
that we might need from analyzing these
papers to make these interactions
possible we've already talked a little
bit about definition detection where
that is and where it's going another
thing that I want to highlight is
something that is kind of hidden in
plain sight is the effort is the efforts
around simple localization which
actually ends up being a relatively
tricky problem
how do you find symbols and their
precise bounding boxes within a paper
unambiguously
um and so where we started for this is
simply to make the initial assumption
that we have the latex available for the
paper this is an assumption you can make
for like a 1.5 million papers on archive
it's one that you can't make for the
remaining like 100 million years or
research articles that are out there
hopefully with latex you could train a
machine learning algorithm that would
work for the rest of this stuff but we
at least have to start somewhere and so
um when we what we did with latex was um
we we essentially did this kind of big
old hack
um in order to try to figure out those
precise simple locations and let me walk
you through what that with what that
ends up looking like so let's say you
have the latex for a passage that
contains a formula in it like this one
that you can see right here
um if you were to render that latex into
a PDF and then raster that as a bitmap
you would end up getting this pixelized
version that you can see on the right
and one of the ways that you could
detect the the pixel locations of that
formula is if you then wrapped that
formula in some coloring command for
instance to color it orange you
re-raster it and then you just diff
those two images with each other that
that leaves you just the colorized
pixels for that individual formula and
then you can just use a blob detector
that just does kind of a conservative
box around all of it and that's your
bounding box for the formula
that won't get you a precise bounding
box location for that individual formula
now how do we drill down into the
individual pieces of that formula to the
symbols at each of the different levels
recall it again the problem is that the
equation that you can see right here it
doesn't contain five symbols or two
symbols that actually contains eight
symbols in it
um at least eight symbols in it
um and so one thing that we can do in
this case is we can try to derive some
of the structure that we might want to
detect within this formula so we can
take the latex that we've already
detected within the um within the
document and then we could pass it
through some type of parser for instance
catech has like an off-the-shelf open
source parser for for latex uh and then
you end up getting the symbol tree and
each of those Leaf nodes are the
individual characters with net within
that formula
and uh and then what you can do is as
long as you have the the character
offsets of each of those Leaf nodes you
can go in and you can colorize each of
those different symbols each of those
different tokens you can even color you
can batch colorize them different colors
of the rainbow and detect them all at
once using different Hues or something
like that
and then once you identify those
individual tokens you can use that
structural information to coalesce it
into these higher level bounding boxes
um and so this is the type of analysis
that we need in order to be able to
provide these kind of more satisfying
interactions that allow drill down into
those individual definitions this
particular technique is better than
anything that we were able to achieve
with machine learning at the time we're
getting a Precision of 96 a recall of 88
those of you who are really interested
in why a rule-based approach didn't get
100 on both I'd be happy to talk about
some of the minutiaev tech event end
supervising when you're trying to do
something like this it's really
interesting but also really esoteric
um but ends up doing uh getting a high
enough Precision that it starts to feel
actually rather good within a paper
so um I talked about how the first part
of this talk would talk about notation
and I want to do a little bit of a
further dive into talking about symbols
and formulas and trying to uncover The
Horizon of the types of things that we
could do with symbols and formulas to to
be able to support people's
understanding of them
and this brings us to our second chapter
on explaining notation in particular
so
let's say you are a person who didn't
understand the equation for a line right
here
there's a couple of ways that we might
be able to explain this formula one of
these approaches is that is the approach
that I described just before which is
you could add descriptive labels to that
formula for instance conveying that this
formula means that you can compute the
height of a point on a line by taking a
horizontal position of that point
multiplying it by a multiplicative
Factor called the slope and then adding
it to some constant offset I think this
is how a lot of us would look at this
formula
there's at least another one other
approach that you can take to this which
is a more pictorial approach which is
what if you could show what this formula
means pictorially
and you could show a visualization kind
of like this
and then you could colorize the formula
in order to try to visually link the two
together
in a way that conveys that the height of
this point on this line you can get
there by taking this constant vertical
offset and then taking the horizontal
offset of this point on the line
multiplying it by this Factor adding it
all together and then you end up with
this end up Computing this height
um which ends up raising this question
are there other mechanisms that we can
use in order to in order to help explain
notation what might those mechanisms be
and what might be the barriers in place
to us being able to integrate those into
our current reading experiences
so for this project our goal was to
understand how future scholarly
authoring tools and document processing
tools could support more Rich
explanations of math notation
and this was a project that was entirely
mixed methods and qualitative we
undertook two different studies one of
them was a Content analysis where we
took a look at 47 math documents with
what we called augmented math notation
essentially math notation with visual
embellishments to try to support
breedability
and then we analyzed about 300 formulas
that came from those documents
and then we undertook a series of
interviews with 12 authors of these
documents to try to understand the
processes by which they arrived at a
particular representation and then the
efforts that they had to go through to
bring this representation into their
documents
the content analysis ended up being
quite effortful it involved two coders
each of us inspected 281 formulas by
classifying and Counting augmentations
and this involved around 8 000 judgments
a piece across all of these different
formulas and because it was such
detail-oriented work it ended up being
about 50 hours each or so
um through those kind of multiple
iterations
and this ended up leading us to this
taxonomy of different ways in which
notation can be augmented which we
boiled down to four different categories
one of these categories is what we call
Visual notation which is taking
visualizations and embedding them
directly as Expressions within the
formula for instance geometric objects
or little graphs upon which which
represented data upon which computation
was being performed
there's text styling so for instance
introducing color and spacing into a
texture of doing these different types
of text formatting to conveying meaning
there's annotations for instance
introducing labels or Borders or other
types of marks on top of the formula
and then there was also interactivity so
a number of these formulas enabled
people to for instance click and drag on
Expressions within those formulas in
order to modulate their values some of
them even had ways of trickling down
those computations to kind of Downstream
values that appeared on the left hand
side of that formula and so on and so
forth
so there's the four overall categories
and when you look at them in in fine
grain detail or actually 16 different
kinds of augmentation that we observed
across these different types of
documents which just shows that there's
actually these relatively large space of
of
um of types of expressions of
augmentations that one would want to
support if they wanted to be able to
support the types of things that we were
already seeing in the wild
taking this taxonomy together with our
interviews with these authors this ended
up leading us to a number of
recommendations about if we were to try
to support the kinds of practices that
they were talking about what would you
make possible in contemporary authoring
tools
so the first recommendation is to help
authors color formulas and the content
that they those formulas relate to we
saw in uh in the vast majority of the
documents that they made use of color to
highlight important expressions and then
relate them to explanations and
representations elsewhere in the
document
so here you can see an example from one
one such document and the the use of the
color green in this particular formula
is just meant to provide an easy way of
scanning back and forth between that f
of x and the curve that it corresponds
to in the in the nearby visualization
this pattern was really common and was
used to link formulas not only to not
only these visualizations but also text
and code listings
um we also saw um we also saw some
desire among these authors to better
support details on demand and animations
so details on demand would be kind of of
the sort that we described with equation
diagrams before
the animations
um one of the visions that we saw of
this was the one that I shared before
which is that there's this one author
who had this derivation that took place
over the course of I think eight steps
you can see two of those steps right
here and there's a lot of this a kind of
accompanying text that describes how to
perform these primitive manipulations to
that formula in order to transform it
into the other one and actually you know
straight out of this particular
participant's mouths there say they said
well I might just want to highlight that
gamma and then just show where it goes
within the next Formula of course
animation isn't necessarily the only way
that you can convey this information but
at least it at least indicates the fact
that a lot of the time text is carrying
the weight of something that can be
shown perhaps more effectively in some
other type of visual representation
another recommendation is I think you
know after we use the tools for long
enough sometimes it's easy to forget
that the markup languages that we use
are sometimes clunky to read and write
and so for instance for a relatively
simple formula like the one that you can
see here that just has eight colorized
symbols within it uh the the code in
order to produce it is what you can see
right here it ends up becoming I think
it's like a 400 character long listing
and what's particularly clunky about
this particular example is the way that
it mixes together the formula
specification which is now fragmented
and way spread out
with the augmentation specification
which is kind of surrounding it and
splitting it up in all of all these
different places and so one might think
that you might be able to fix this
fragmentation problem and also some of
the verbosity problem with another type
of design so for instance if you were to
think about if you were to come up with
like a CSS for formulas maybe instead it
would look like you would have your
content markup for the formula what
would just be the formula and allow
people to continue to look at that text
for the formula as usual
and then you would have your
presentation markup which allows people
to for instance select different types
of expressions and then apply simple
styles to them with a more concise
readable syntax
so those three design recommendations I
shared with you are just three of eleven
that we came up with on this paper on
the basis of the the observations of
both the documents and the interviews um
if you're really interested in this I
think that there's a whole lot of really
cool tools that can be built in this
space in order to help people interact
with formulas more effectively um so I
encourage you to take a look at the
paper if this is peaking your curiosity
if I were to take a step back I would
say that the overall takeaways from from
from that particular study was that to
support Rich explanations of math
notation our scholarly media and
authoring tools should be extended to
support linking of text and notation
supporting a wide variety of annotations
and also perhaps in judicious uh in in
appropriate circumstances supporting
more Dynamic formula presentations
so um let's go back to this more General
problem of helping people understand
texts through interactivity
we started out this talk talking about
the prevalence of vocabulary and trying
to help people understand individual
terms and symbols but I think that there
is a particular critique that could be
leveled against this which is that
sometimes the problems with
understanding the text cannot be
explained purely by vocabulary and so
here's a quote from Mark Halliday who's
uh who's uh who's a renowned linguist
and he wrote this paper on grammatical
problems and understanding scientific
English and
um I really like what he writes here in
that he wrote In order to understand why
scientific writing has become difficult
in certain ways we shall need to get rid
of our obsession with words the
difficulty lies more with the grammar
than with the vocabulary
and I think that we can see some of what
Mark Halliday was saying if we look at a
passage from for instance a biomedical
text and I'm just going to read this
biomedical this this passage out loud
where you start to see that the problem
isn't necessarily individual words but
perhaps the ways that they're being
combined together
and this passage reads the most Salient
events include an impaired apoptosis of
dying cells a type 1 interferon
signature the uncontrolled activation of
T and B lymphocytes and the production
of autoantibodies mainly directed
against nucleic acids or
ribonucleoproteins
so here's the case where the terminology
is so dense and also the structure of
the sentence is complex enough and it's
going to be difficult for someone to
understand this even if they understand
each of the individual terms
this ended up leading to our third
chapter which is on simplifying the
complex in interactive papers
um and the particular focus of this
project was to try to kind of take this
to the extreme of of trying to kind of
democratize access to a paper we were
really interested in thinking about if
you took Healthcare consumers and tried
to allow them to access some of the
latest results about conditions and
treatments in the medical literature as
oftentimes they they desire to do how
would you be able to do that with an
interface
um and the lead for this project is tall
August um if you're interested in his
work um you should definitely check it
out he does some great work in ACI and
NLP he's on the job market right now and
I think really excited to talk about a
lot of these different types of projects
that he worked on
so um this project like many of our
others began with some formative
research
um in this case we conducted interviews
with Healthcare consumers and then
observation studies with non-expert
readers around biomedical papers and
through these observations and
interviews we ended up distilling this
set of questions that people would ask
while reading these biomedical papers
without without domain expertise
some of these questions might be things
like what should I read
um another question might be where can I
find an answer to a specific question
that I have about a text
and then rather than asking a question
about what this term means they might
have the question of what does this
passage as a whole mean
these were three of the five questions
that we ended up uh Illuminating and I
want to talk about them in particular
we ended up developing this interface
called paper plane plane in the title
meaning referring to the plain language
summaries that we intended to
incorporate into the reading experience
in order to help people understand the
complex information within that paper
and it was designed to answer these
three questions
So within paper plane the first aspect
that you'll notice that's different from
a conventional PDF reader is that
instead of your typical navigation for a
paper you instead have this uh this bar
on the left which is called the key
question index and what this key
question index does is it lists these
eight common questions that lay
audiences might wish to ask about
biomedical research
and so implicitly this key question and
index is intended to answer this
question of what should I read
essentially it cues up these different
sets of things that someone might be
interested about within this particular
paper
and then when a reader has a particular
one of these questions that they want to
understand better they can move their
Mouse over to it and they can highlight
it
and then just the act of hovering over
that particular question ends up
answering the second question of where
can I find an answer to my question
because when someone hovers over that
text it will highlight the corresponding
passage within the text
and then when someone clicks on that
particular question it will then jump
them to to that answering Passage
and then this brings us to the answer to
the third question in particular of
what does this passage mean
and so what you can see is that whenever
someone jumps to an answer we show what
is called an answer gist which is a
plain Language summary of the content uh
the answering passage and so um I'll
just briefly read this just for you up
on the screen to give you a better sense
of the type of language that this just
is written in in contrast to the passage
I read you before
this just reads systemic lupus
arithmetosis is a disease that affects
about 5 million people in the world
mostly women it is an autoimmune disease
which means that your body attacks
itself it can affect many different
parts of your body including your
kidneys and your brain it can be
unpredictable meaning that it can change
from being active to being quiet it can
flare up when you get sick or have a
cold
and so the idea behind these summaries
is that they're meant to to state things
in simpler sentences with simpler
terminology that are going to be more
approachable
but still being adjacent to the to the
original text to allows someone to go
back and look at that kind of ground
truth
and so paper plane doesn't just provide
these gists related to the uh to the
answers within the within the paper but
essentially they allow people to ask him
about any section that they'd like so
given a section like this one which is a
very long description of a particular
type of I believe therapeutic peptide
that is being covered within this paper
someone can click on that flag right
next to that section
and then they end up saying once again
what is a a briefer and more plainly
stated summary of that section which
should help them be able to understand
for instance try even bother looking at
this particular section does it contain
the kinds of information that I might
wish to understand
so in this way paper plane was designed
to answer the questions of what should I
read where can I find an answer to my
question and what does this passage mean
and as with scholarify you know one of
the uh one of the tests of This research
was to get a sense of what it would take
to build up an interactive paper like
this
and in our experience what implementing
a paper simplifier entailed was a number
of different
um a number of different implementation
choices so for the key choices in
particular those questions were chosen
from the Pico set of questions as well
as the questions that came from the
Cochrane guide on writing uh uh writing
um understandable summaries of
biomedical research and so we
essentially kind of joined together
merge together and Consolidated those
sets of questions into the key questions
that you saw there
the answer to the key questions were
extracted by applying a model that was
trained on the bio ask text to all of
the paragraphs within the paper and any
paragraph that yielded an answer was
seen as an answering question an
answering Passage
and then the plain language summaries
were generated by gpt3 I think a lot of
us have been playing around with gpt3
and other related large language models
these days
um what we essentially did was uh we we
took text from the answering passages or
from the sections and then we passed it
through a prompt asking it to re-explain
it as if it was um trying to describe
the same passage at a fifth grade
reading level
and to try to get a sense of the ways in
which uh uh which these types of
affordances would affect the reading
experience we conducted a study with not
24 non-expert meters we had them on to
take a reading task
where they read a paper for 10 minutes
and then answered questions about that
paper and then
um
and we also um we had a we had a partial
within subjects design where each reader
was assigned to two of four interfaces
where which were essentially different
ablations of the different features of
paper plane
and one of our observations uh from from
this study was that we started to see
this transition from not using paper
plane to Paper Plane where we saw people
going from more exhaustive reading
patterns to more piecemeal reading
patterns so let me decompose this
visualization a little bit
one of these curves is one reader on one
paper
and the position on the y-axis
corresponds to their position within the
paper so for this particular person you
can see that up until around minute four
or five or so they were mostly in the
beginning of the paper then they jumped
towards the end they jump back to kind
of the beginning and then they jump to
the end again and then kind of scroll
back up to the top so that's how to read
that particular curve
and um
what I want to highlight is if you look
at this particular set of Curves which
corresponds to when people were using a
conventional uh when people did not have
access to the key question index you saw
what essentially looks like this
exhaustive linear reading where people
kind of just slowly plot along from the
beginning to the end of the paper
sometimes jumping back for a second pass
when you look at the key question index
you start to see more of this kind of
piecemeal sampling of the paper a lot of
this I'm not I don't show it on this
chart but um a lot of this ends up
corresponding to a lot more time spent
in the introduction and the discussion
of the paper which tend to be the kind
of more approachable parts of it
um and what we ended up seeing is that
participants jump to answers an average
of 10 times when the key question index
was available suggesting that this was
seen as something that kind of helped
them navigate to that relevant content
another thing that I'll also mention is
that we also saw a statistically
significantly longer fixation time when
the key question index was available
which suggests that at any given place
where someone stopped they were spending
more time looking at that information
there there's just an interesting
observation we can't necessarily say
that led to better understanding so to
speak our better engagement but it was a
it was a market difference in in the
reading process
now the effect on understanding papers
was a little bit confusing from the
perspective of trying to reconcile
different signals that we got from this
study
so on the one hand participants reported
that it was less difficult to read the
paper and that they better understood
the paper when using paper plane which
is great A big upgrade if people feel
that a paper is more approachable with
with it with the use of these kinds of
features
um that said participants answered
questions about the paper about this
correctly with both paper plane and the
Baseline and so this is this about is
correctly it's not just kind of lack of
statistical significance we did a
follow-up non-inferiority test and um
and uh and and they were shown as kind
of statistically likely to be uh uh for
neither of them to be inferior or
Superior to each other
um so all of us suggest that I think
first of all comprehension is this
really complex thing is 10 minute
interactions with a tool are perhaps not
enough to to move the needle on it and
we need to keep inquiring about how to
build these tools to move the needle in
understandable metrics uh on um on these
kind of quantifiable metrics of
understandability
um I guess uh at the same time one of
the things that is good is that some of
these simplifications do not seem to
diminish the ability to answer those
questions
um but rather it was able to at least
keep parity
so um
I want to I want to take a step back
um and and and and and to try to talk
about how we can bring about a vision of
more comprehensive interactive papers
so first just taking stock of what we've
talked about so far we've talked about
how an interactive paper should Define
terms explain notation and live in the
static and simplify the complex the way
that I would summarize the findings from
the studies that we've run so far is
that readers desire tools for looking up
definitions of terms and symbols
authoring tools are not keeping Pace
with kinds of explanations authors would
like to provide and that readers report
lower difficulty reading papers within
situ simplifications
um but one might also notice that
there's a lot more than an interactive
paper could do particularly for
different kinds of reading modes for
instance maybe when someone is skimming
an interactive paper could draw
attention to important passages or maybe
when someone is conducting some some
early stage research within an area
um an interactive paper could draw
attention to important citations and in
fact
some of my collaborators in some of my
collaborations with the semantic scholar
team we've been exploring a lot of these
ideas too so to just describe a bit of
the emerging work that you'll see at
conferences just later this year
Raymond Fox just read this project on
this project on this project called skim
which is the word skim but with a c for
Science and it provided intelligent
skimming support and so what this tool
does is it um it processes the paper and
then it highlights sentences according
to four different facets of whether they
talk about methods objectives novelty uh
novelty statements or or results and it
tries to distribute these highlights in
such a way that will allow people to
kind of gain purchase on kind of that
messy middle of the paper that you might
not get using your conventional skimming
heuristics so this is a project that
that we recently worked on to try to
help people with this process of rapidly
extracting a lot of information out of a
paper during a skim
another project that was intended to
help out help someone get better
orientation to the literature was this
project called sightsee which was led by
Joseph chi chong and the parts of the
site C interface that I want to draw
your attention to is first of all you
have these highlighted citations and
these citations become highlighted when
you see them for a second or a later
time while reading papers so sightsee
keeps track of the papers that you've
seen in the past and if these citations
keep appearing time and time again it'll
start letting you know about that in
order to try to convey you might want to
read this by now
and in this tool tip that you can see
right here there's this additional
information that tries to convey
information about those contexts in
which you learned about this citation
before so for instance on this
particular site citation was cited by
one of the recent readings which was the
crystalline paper you had scrawled 83 of
the way through the paper and the
citation context within that paper in
which you had originally seen it was
this one right here so what it's trying
to do is essentially take What Might
Have Been a much more difficult task of
trying to understand the context in
which you encountered these citations
and should try to bring all that
information into one place to help you
make those kind of momentary decisions
about what to do with an individual
citation
I think there's also an important
question about how we can do all of
these things in a way that best befits
an individual reader rather than making
these kind of all um one-size-fits-all
interactions and so
um one might ask how could you
personalize the reading experience
noticing that for instance that within a
particular uh within a particular page
of a paper you might have these
different classes of these terms that
that belong to these different domains
and people might be familiar with one of
those domains but not another So within
this particular page there are these
terms that are related to deep learning
there are these terms that are related
to computational Linguistics there are
terms related to other types of domains
too and any given reader is going to
have familiar with some of those and not
with others how do we help detect
certain clusters of terms that are going
to be relevant to a particular person
um there's also this challenge of
figuring out how to explain it in a way
that's approachable to a particular
person so for instance you could
describe a soft Max function in a couple
of ways which might be fit different
readers
you can describe it as simply just a
function that maps from this infinite
domain into a value from zero to one and
that might just be sufficient for some
people to know
other people might be interested in the
kind of formal the formerly specified
definition of it and so perhaps we
should understand the types of things
that readers know and personalize these
definitions to them
using the language of the user
and across all of these different
projects what we need to do is
essentially orchestrate a whole lot of
different techniques from document
analysis where it can detect entities
and bounding boxes to work with
Publishers in order to make documents
interactive and to distribute authoring
tools to work with NLP researchers for
technology to simplify texts reduce
hallucinations in those texts and Beyond
and also us HDI researchers of course
I'm trying to you know take the lead in
understanding these different reading
modes and the different forms of support
that we can provide and really kind of
nuanced detail as they might manifest in
these really complex information
artifacts
in order to help us fit what can be
oftentimes these very complex papers
into our minds and then be able to
benefit from the collective knowledge
that we've all been cultivating as a
research community
and with that I'd like to welcome
questions
foreign
thank you for a great talk Andrew
um my question was I wanted to get your
thoughts on sort of like I feel like you
presented a lot of work on augmenting
like existing text but I think there's
been some conversation around for
instance like having videos being
embedded in papers or like why are PDFs
like eight and a half by eleven if
they're being consumed online like that
seems like an arbitrary restriction so I
guess like what are your takes or
thoughts on different kinds of
interactivity in papers Beyond sort of
like yeah like augmenting the text
that's there yeah I think that's a great
point so I think there's a there's a bit
of a
philosophy behind a lot of the work that
you you saw today around essentially
trying to improve a text by
incorporating additional reference
information in a timely way and I think
that there's a lot of really exciting
things to be pursued and for instance
aligning text to like slide uh slide
lectures and video talks and that kind
of stuff um and I also think that what
you also identified like giving
additional breathability and reflowing
the text is another way that you can do
this as well
um I think all of that work needs to be
done and should be done
um some of my colleagues at semantic
scholar have worked on some of that
stuff too um for instance one of the
projects that they worked on was called
PSI Ally and what it does is it takes a
pdf version of a paper and then
generates a reflowable text version of
it with some additional accessibility
features in it as well so I think that
work should be done
um and so we should work on that as well
uh uh so yeah it was great to see all
the examples Andrew
um I have a question about
uh what happens when the automated
summaries or the other automated things
are incorrect right you know there's a
big potential for leading someone astray
and how do you think about that and you
know what should be done there yeah
that's a great question and in fact
one thing that I
um
skipped over in the interest of getting
to the end of this talk
but I did want to talk about is this
whole this whole challenge of
hallucinations in some of this generated
texts so um you know the fact that we
picked biomedicine as a challenge area
it really highlights the potential
downsides of hallucinations and that a
patient might end up drawing incorrect
conclusions about potential conditions
and treatments has real impact on their
health and well-being I mean so um to
validate your concern um one example
that I do have here is a place where um
you know an example simplification that
we did where um here's an excerpt that
you can see and it's corresponding
generated gist and so on the left hand
side you can see that kind of the
concluding statement is the median jotus
score of the cohort studies was six
indicating that these studies were of
high quality and on the right hand side
you can see that kind of the concluding
statement is the study found that all
three types of surgery were effective
for treating the problem and so this is
an example where essentially there was
kind of this hallucination of this
conclusion that was never explicitly
stated within that text
um and so
um we thought about this a lot as part
of this project and I think it's
something that we as a community need to
kind of continue referring to like how
we how we accept the fact that
hallucinations are part of lots of these
models and responsibly deploy them the
ways that we thought about it for this
particular project is that first the
simplification should appear adjacent to
the source text so one of the ways that
we were thinking about this project is
that we don't just want to kind of
staple a summary to the very beginning
of the text but rather we want to have
these simplifications be kind of like an
index into the text it's a reason why we
don't occlude the text with any of those
descriptions either because our hope is
that someone is going to eventually
bottom out at that original text to get
to that kind of authoritative
description
um second
um generated text should be clearly
marked as such so it should be clear to
people this was generated
and then um third I think in the long
term you know incorporating some
technologies around checking facts and
hallucinations and that kind of stuff is
something that should be done to make
sure to to reduce to the extent possible
the prevalence of those hallucinations
so those are some of the ways that we've
thought about it so far
um but I think it's a really important
point that needs to be considered with a
creation of all these Technologies
yeah I think relying on the user to
check
doesn't simplify reading right or it
doesn't make it easier right it makes it
potentially harder so that's that's that
could be a little odds with what you're
trying to do yeah I think that's a good
point I mean I think um one of the ways
that I think about the paper plane
project I think about the
simplifications as Vehicles into the
text rather than replacements for it
um I think that of course there's a
temptation as soon as you introduce a
simplification that someone is going to
read purely that and not the the the the
original text too um and so I I think
that is a risk and and and and and and
perhaps one that we haven't solved
um but I think that you know
philosophically I don't necessarily
think about completely removing the need
to re read that original text as the
that wasn't my goal in this project and
I think that perhaps it shouldn't be our
goal at least for domains like
biomedical texts
thanks
hello yeah I have a question cool um I
really liked the talk particularly when
you were motivating within the related
work and you talked about the textbooks
where it was created interactive Avenue
for students to be able to see and
understand the things that were going on
within the textbook I'm curious to have
your take on when it comes to I know
this was particularly for maybe adults
or something trying to read and learn
about these new different types of
treatments and such but in terms of what
are the possibly like when it comes to
being able to ask a question or not just
using the generated question but what if
I want to know given my conditions of
XYZ is this a very good and proposed
method to treat my ABC and what are the
I guess capabilities of being able to do
that just as they would with the
textbook of someone could ask a question
and get the answer would you also be
able to do that within the scientific
papers yeah so um there are a couple of
projects that I've tried to address just
that so for instance um there was this
project called talk to papers which try
to incorp great question answering into
into a paper setting in order to be able
to provide answers to arbitrary
questions that people ask I think it's a
really good idea and I think that if
Incorporated in the right way I think it
could answer a lot of questions that
people have there's also something else
that um
that you mentioned in your question that
I think is also a really interesting
area for exploration which is helping
people relate the findings in a paper to
their personal circumstances especially
kind of in the biomedical space trying
to understand how the results of a study
might uh might um
might relate to them specifically given
the fact that different types of
treatments and conditions affect people
differently that in fact was something
that we found out in our learned about
narrow informative studies as well and
something I think would be really
interesting to figure out different ways
of incorporating
um maybe a question answering I think
another thing that could be looked into
is other types of like patient anecdotes
and that kind of stuff to help people
get these very kind of
people-centric and descriptions of what
can sometimes be very abstract results
so um I think you hit upon a couple of
really exciting areas for future future
exploration
hello
um I have a question about I guess maybe
it's a second order effect of some of
the things that you talked about so in a
world where like this is just like like
fully implemented into like all PDF
readers
have you thought about how this changes
how people write so I can think of two
ways in one where it's just like people
just write super archaic because we're
like they're like there's going to be
some model that can just understand what
I'm saying and then in another way it's
like I'm thinking okay people aren't
reading like these models aren't picking
up most of what I'm writing so I'm just
gonna like write less text
um in general have you thought about
like kind of like these effects of like
these models on how people are actually
going to write
right so um
the thing that we would want to avoid as
you mentioned is if these tools end up
becoming a crutch for people's writing
where essentially they're kind of
offload
some of the effective writing strategies
to something that can be caught by it by
an interface later on
um
I uh I don't know if that would be
likely to happen
um I think it is something that you
would want to avoid and I think that in
part one of the things that we should
maybe consider is like simultaneously
making improvements to the authoring
process while we're also making changes
to the reading process that continue to
encourage people to write in ways that
are going to be approachable to other
people
um uh and in a way that kind of
continues to to explain that like the
onus really is on the author to make
their text understandable so um I don't
know the effect I think it would be a
fascinating study to run and hopefully
we would not end up in such a situation
I think we're in about a time so let's
thank you
[Applause]